well i have an opportunity today to do
two things that i think are valuable one
is debunk a false talking point that is
spreading like wildfire and number two
to remind everybody that the entire
tulsi gabbard thing was a complete and
total scam tulsi gabbard who
i guess somebody
thought was on the left at one point
when she ran for president and when she
was a democrat
she continues to provide uh reactionary
takes on fox news
and last night she provided a
reactionary take that is a great
opportunity to explain reality
uh to her and to people in the audience
and to make sure that we're all equipped
with the truth about this question did
the supreme court leaker
commit a crime
because for all the talk about due
process that the right claims to support
they are increasingly demanding the
prosecution and imprisonment of the
supreme court leaker
absent any actual
crime
that we can point to that they committed
so let's start with tulsi you might be
shocked that tulsi appeared to express
outrage
that the decision leaked
not
that women's autonomy will now be
allowed to be restricted by states
she was outraged that we learned about
this three weeks early let's take a
listen to be heard
i think it's also critical to point out
that uh this leak sets a very very
dangerous precedent for our supreme
court for three important reasons number
one is first of all this person
is a thief who stole this information
released it with a very specific intent
to try to incite protesters and
intimidate and pressure our supreme
court justices to make a political
decision rather than a decision that is
based on the constitution uh number two
we have the fact that um you know the
supreme court is not in place to
legislate from the bench uh people's
representatives and yet that's exactly
what they're doing with this decision
state level at the federal level are
charged to make laws not the supreme
court the supreme court needs to make
decisions uh based on the constitution
and the department of justice lastly
needs to go and prosecute this uh crime
which is exactly what it is and make an
example out of the person who leaked
this information because our supreme
court justices cannot operate under the
fear that they will have partisan
political activists in their house uh
intimidating and threatening their
ability to do their job per the
constitution okay
so tulsi uses the word thief and that
sounds criminal i don't know theft is
illegal right
but it wasn't that we know of a crime so
that's one thing i'm going to talk about
the second piece of this is she insists
that this was
uh someone who didn't like
the forthcoming decision to overturn roe
v wade
meaning it's presumably someone on the
left who leaked this in order to try to
pressure the justices to change their
minds
and sometime between now and whenever
the decision comes out
decide to preserve roe v wade i'll get
to that part in a second so let's start
with the crime piece this is not about
your opinion of whether it was good or
bad that this leaked three weeks early i
just want to talk about whether it's a
crime
if to get to this document
someone at the supreme court
hacked a computer they weren't supposed
to have access to
physically trespassed somewhere that
could be a crime we have no evidence of
any hacking or trespassing right now
secondly supreme court draft decisions
are not classified that's another angle
where this is sort this this must be
like a classified document it's not so
there's no crime there either
if i want to be as charitable as
possible and say where could there be a
crime here under the loosest
interpretation possible
you could maybe be charged with stealing
federal government property for your own
use it's extraordinarily unlikely that
you would see that it's not even clear
that it would necessarily fit now if an
investigation starts
and
authorities interview anyone the leaker
or whoever and you lie to them okay
that's a crime that would be making a
federal false uh statement charge
but that's an if okay so
there's no crime that we're aware of
here so why would anybody be prosecuted
and locked up because that's what people
like tulsi and other reactionaries are
calling for now one other thing if the
leaker is a lawyer
they could be subject to an ethics probe
they could be subject to being disbarred
it's these aren't crimes but they could
lose their law license bottom line
firing sure disbarment if a lawyer sure
crime almost certainly not no evidence
of that at this point in time second
part
um
they continue to assume these right
wingers
that the leaker
is a pro-choice
left winger
angry with the forthcoming decision to
overturn roe v wade
releasing this draft in order to try to
put public pressure on the justices
planning to vote in favor of overturning
roe v wade so they will be scared and
they'll change their mind and they will
vote to keep roe v wade first of all
lifetime appointments
extremely good security i don't even
think it passes the sniff test that it
would work if that's what the plan was
to intimidate the justices planning to
vote to overturn but i actually have
another perspective here which is
we're we're only speculating we don't
know who the leaker is
the leaker could just as likely be a
right winger
who leaked this
in order to try to lock in the justices
in sticking with their decision to
overturn roe v wade in other words a
right winger might say
there might be justices who in this
february draft
wanted to vote to overturn roe v wade
but now maybe because it's may now
remember this person might know what
happened since the draft was written
maybe the leaker is a right winger
doesn't like abortion and says wow i
found out that i don't know gorsuch is
thinking about actually voting to keep
roe v wade
i am going to leak this to make their
names public
so that they are less likely to change
their vote because that would
potentially cause some kind of uproar or
whatever the point is we don't know
either way right now at some point we
might right now we don't know and all of
this is completely irresponsible
particularly saying that people who have
not committed any crime that we're aware
of or that can be articulated should be
prosecuted and put in prison as so many
like ted cruz have been demanding
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magic magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman